اسابيع قليله تفصلنا عن حفل الزفاف الملكي
لولي العهد الاردني الامير الحسين بن عبد
الله الثاني وذلك على خطيبته السعوديه
رجوى بنت خالد السيف وهذا زفاف مرتقب
اقامته يوم الاول من يونيو المقبل طبعا
التجهيزات على قدم وساق لتنظيم هذا الحفل
المهيب سيحضرها زعماء ورؤساء دول وشخصيات
عربيه وعالميه رفيعه المستوى ويحييه نخبه
من نجوم الفن الحكومه الاردنيه عممت على
الوزارات
والمؤساءات احتفاليه من المقرر اقامتها
خلال الفتره من السادس والعشرين من مايو
الى الاول من يونيو فيما اعلنت يوم اليوم
الاول من يونيو او واحد يونيو عطله رسميه
في الاردن وتحت وسم نفرح بالحسين نشر
الديوان الملكي الهاشميه شعار الرسمي
لمناسبه عقد قران سمو الامير الحسين بن
عبد الله الثاني قبل الذهاب مشاهدينا الى
العاصمه الاردنيه عمان الحديث عن تفاصيل
هذا العرس والزفاف الملكي الزميله لميس
راح تعرفنا اكثر على بطلي هذه المناسبه
الاسطوريه
اعلنت ديوان الملكي الهاشمي يوم الاربعاء
السابع عشر من اغسطس في عام 2022 عن خطوبه
الامير الحسين من الانسه رجوى خالد بن
مساعد بن سيف بن عبد العزيز ال سيف فمن هي
هذه السعوديه التي ستصبح اميره في الاردن
هي مهندسه معماريه تبلغ من العمر 29 عاما
ولدت في الرياض وتلقت تعليمها الثانوي في
السعوديه ثم درست الهندسه المعماريه في
جامعه سيراكولوس في نيويورك في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
والدها اصوله من قبيله السبيعي وهو رجل
اعمال ومالك شركه السيف للمقاولات
الهندسيه المحدوده وبعد الزواج ستحصل رجوى
على لقب زوجه ولي العهد الاردني على غرار
صاحب السمو الملكي وبمجرد زواجها رسميا من
ولي العهد ستكون رجوى قادره على التمثيل
ولي العهد في المناسبات مثل حفلات الزفاف
اعضاء العائلات الملكيه
[موسيقى]
درب
الحمر واقف خبيني درب الحب واقف صفيني
الشعب يغني الامير حسين الشعبي
الى الامير حسين صلوا العرسان وطلتهم
مهيوبه الله العرسان
فرحتنا اليوم على القمر مكتوب فرحتنا
اليوم على الق
[تصفيق]
ومات ايضا عن العرس مشاهدينا الاميره
الحسين بن عبد الله الثاني يبلغ من العمر
29 عاما وهو الابن البكر للملك عبد الله
الثاني ابن الحسين من زوجته الملكه رانيا
العبد الله
وهو بحسب ووفق خط الخلافه على العرش
الاردني هو الوريد لعرش المملكه الاردنيه
الهاشميه بعد ابيه الملك عبد الله الثاني
بن الحسين منذ بلوغه سن الرشد القانوني
عام 2022 تولى الاميره الحسين مسؤوليات
كثيره ورافق والده الملك عبد الله الثاني
في عدد من الزيارات الدوليه والمحليه بالف
عل الحسين تعليمه ثانوي
في مادبا في الاردن حصل على تعليمه
الجامعي في التاريخ الدولي من جورج تاون
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه عام 2016
ايضا تخرج الامير الحسين من اكاديميه سانت
هرتست العسكريه الملكيه في بريطانيا عام
2017 ويحمل رتبه نقيب في القوات المسلحه
الاردنيه
[موسيقى]
من عمان ينضم الينا مراسل صباح العربيه
عماد العضائي الى عماد صبحك الله بالخير
اليوم
طيب يا عماد ما هي التجهيزات اللي يعني
عمان والاردن بدات في التحضير لها لهذا
العرس المرتقب
صباح الخير عادل صباح الخير راويه طبعا
يعني هو باختصار شديد هو عرس اردني
بتقاليد البيت الهاشمي العريق وبكل بساطه
يعني هذا العرس هو يشبه بحد الى حد كبير
عرس كل اردني من حيث الفعاليات التي
سترافق هذا هذا حفل الزفاف هذا منذ يوم
امس كان هناك حفله سمر في
ضمن يعني الرفاق السلاح للولي العهد
الامير الحسين قاموا بهذا بهذه الحفلات
وهذه بهذه الحفله وهذه الحفلات يعني تمتاز
ان تكون لشباب او لرفاق العريس بعد ذلك
يعني لم يتم الاعلان رسميا عن مراسم حفل
الزفاف لكن وكما ومن خلال الدعوات التي
وصلت
للاردنيين وغير الاردنيين من خلال هذه
الدعوات من قبل العاهل الاردني الملك عبد
الله ومن قبل ايضا الملكه رانيا العبد
الله دعت لهذا دعوا لهذه
الفعاليات هنا اقف يعني في منطقه جبل عمان
وتحديدا مقابل قصر زهران الذي سيكون فيه
يعقد فيه عقد قران الامير ولي العهد
الاردني الملك الحسين بن عبد الله على
الانسه رجوى ال سيف سيخرج من هنا من بعد
هذا بعد عقد القران سيخرج موكب وهو يعني
ما يعرف كما تحدثنا انه يشبه كل الاعراس
الاردنيين وهذا ما يعرف عنا
بالفارده وهي سيكون هناك موكب ملكي نعم
اتفضل كمل قبل ما اسالك ما هي الفرده كمل
نعم سيخرج هاي يعني هي يعني الفارده
بالمعنى
يعني بالعرس الاردني وهو الموكب الذي
سيخرج به
العروسان من هذه البوابه وسيخرج ضمن
الموكب الاحمر الذي بالعاده يتم يعني
للاستقبال الزعماء او للحفل افرح وللعلم
هذه يعني هذا القصر قصر زهران هو من اقدم
القصور الملكيه الهاشميه
وشهد ايضا
حفل يعني الكثير من الاعراس اهمها الملكيه
طبعا اهمها عرس والده
الملك العهد الاردني الملك عبد الله
الثاني وايضا الملك الحسين الراحل الملك
الحسين بن طلال نعم طيب عماد يعني تعودنا
بالاعراس الملكيه مثلا للعائله المالكه
البريطانيه هذا الجانب العام من يعني من
احتفالات الزواج هل هناك جانب عام من هذه
المناسبه الخاصه بحيث يشارك الشعب الاردني
الاحتفال بهذا الزفاف الملكي ام انه يعني
عادات العائله الملكيه الاردنيه بالمحافظه
على الخصوصيه بشكل اكبر مما نشهده يعني من
زفاف ملكي في العالم
راويه كما تحدثت قبل قليل انه عرس ملكي
يعني يمتاز بالبساطه ويشبه كل اعراس
الاعراس الاردنيه وامتاز ايضا بقربه من
الناس سيكون هناك نقاط تجمع في الشوارع
التي
سيمر منها الموكب الملكي للتعبير عن
الهويه الاردنيه الوطنيه من خلال ايضا
الفعاليات الاخرى
هناك يعني فعاليه دعت لها الملكه رانيا
العبد الله
لنساء اردنيات وسيدات اردنيات لحفل في
مضارب بني هاشم لحضور حفل العشاء يعني
تقريبا هي ليله الحناء وهناك ايضا دعوه من
العهد الاردني الملك عبد الله الثاني
للاردنيين ايضا في مضارب بني هاشم يعني
وهذا ما يعرف لدينا في الاردن او في
الاعراس الاردنيه او بالمصطلح يعني اللغه
العربيه الفصحى القرى نعم شكرا جزيلا يا
عماد العضائي لمراسل صباح العربيه من عمان
اكيد راح نكون يعني احنا بهذه التفاصيل
اكثر حينما يقترب الموعد في الاول من
يونيو شكرا جزيلا لك ودامت افرحكم
او ده يعني
عامره بالافراح باذن الله شكرا
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات